the first thing I did after I you know
got out the airport was I had to get
some money out and I had no this is my
first time in Vietnam so and I didn't
Google this before so I had no like
inkling of what the conversion rate was
so you're scammed uh no I put in my I
put in my cards uh and you know I
normally you gauge how much you can take
out by what they allow you to take out
right yeah so the maximum amount uh you
could take out of this ATM that's you
know unless you like insert an actual
number was 2 million Dong
and I was like that sounds like a lot
you know what I'm gonna take out one
million Dong that's probably gonna last
me the entire trip yeah Google why don't
you Google oh wait I was in a rush
because uh my mate was amazing he was
ripping off his bike
so I was like God damn I'm a Vietnamese
millionaire I have I've got the cash I
saw I get the million now I go that's my
mail I was like I got a million is that
a lot and he just looks me dead in the
eye and goes nope that's uh 30 quid you
got there
Bank fees are probably more than that
yeah
I can't [__] damn it uh but yeah I
mean aside basically I did two things on
uh in Vietnam just go around and try a
bunch of food uh and write about it ride
around on motorcycle and uh go to some
local bars that's that's all you need so
[__] pumped because I need to go in
June and I'm just hearing about this I'm
like I'm trying to convince my parents
yeah like we need to get mopeds yeah I
might if if we're not [__] you guys I'm
going on a moped because I'm a changed
man now I've learned the moped ways in
Hawaii yeah I mean it's like any other
Southeast Asian country the street food
is just oh it's it's insane like tried
my first like local ban me yeah which
was like a Vietnamese kind of sandwich
yeah they have uh they have a lot of
bread there that's uh
I mean I think it's good
I don't know how much my opinion is
worth but uh because I'd like to try
this bread yeah I'll try for myself yeah
because because they're a lot of their
culture revolve revolves around like ban
me uh because you can get it like every
combini and there's so many like street
food stalls that sell ban me this is the
one where they put like a [__] ton of
coriander yeah yeah that's just all
Vietnamese yeah that's just Vietnamese
food and I remember like uh we went to a
fast store as well and having fun with
the ban me bread bro that my third eye
open man because I've had far before but
I've never had it with like the local
band yeah you just I was just like oh
Southeast Asian people can do bread it's
it's maybe it's just Thailand that's
just [__] up red man and I bet that
costs like 50 cents or something yeah
you think about it I don't see a single
bread no in Thailand no I don't see it I
remember I remember going back to
Thailand for the last month and uh I
wanted a sandwich and
we ordered the sandwich and I don't know
what it is about Thailand bread but the
sun most of the places you have even if
it's a bougie looking place all the
bread is like sweet it's like sweet
bread even for sandwiches it's like in
Korea it's garlic bread I was like what
is this maybe [__] maybe the boys
have poisoned my mind because I don't
remember bread being this bad no or
maybe maybe that's why I just never ate
bread as a kid because it everywhere I
lived bread was just [__] you've had the
real world in Belgium that's pretty good
Brad yeah the bread in Belgium was
[__] it was not the best of it sorry
about Jim yeah I'm I'm discovering my
bread Journey now I think my young age
of 32. okay I'm I'm discovering this man
that's fine
um and yeah just uh had a bunch of like
the street food local food uh but one
thing I did notice is that everything in
there is also like sweet there's a big
Coffee Culture there I um took me to a
egg coffee place
I've heard
so you know how you have a latte you
have like the espresso oh no don't tell
me what I think there you have you have
the espresso and then they froth up the
milk so imagine that except they use egg
whites for it
yeah it's honestly actually it kind of
sounds something you're not gonna lie
actually actually pretty damn good all
right I I actually like it okay let me
show you is this good
mail in this egg white coffee good
have you had it
is it egg yolk is that is it good
it's okay okay it's kind of like this
this is what it looks like it looks like
a creme brulee yeah so it's if you
forget the fact that you are drinking a
coffee and treat this more like a
dessert then is it sweet yeah it's sweet
right yeah I mean sweet I might like it
it looks like kind of like a like a
dessert it's kind of it's kind of like
like a middle a perfect middle bit
between like kind of like a drink and a
custard
yeah yeah yeah I wanna yeah it's kind of
it's kind of like it's kind of like
tiramisu but just yeah
so what you said is it's a deconstructed
terms
I would have been on board it's a
reconstruction it's a latte but with
yoke I'm like what the [__] is that tell
me it's a Tiramisu deconstructed I'm
like okay well now okay that sounds good
I mean that isn't that literally what a
Tiramisu is yeah
yeah like I said there's a big Coffee
Culture there there's a lot a lot of
coffee shops is Vietnam the one as well
that has that coffee that like comes
from like the the cat poop
[Applause]
yeah honestly I only spent uh like two
three days there and I already really
want to go back I think two or three
days is like kind of perfect for gauging
A vibe yeah like if you want to come
yeah because I I don't know and that I
used to I used to be like a one-week
person I was like I had a week but now I
feel like one week's too much I'm like I
want three four days I'm gonna be there
for two weeks because all of Vietnam
holy [__] when we're literally traveling
the entire thing if you're traveling all
around I think that's fine like you know
let's say you you're flying into this
major city oh no we're not going to be
in like one city for like more than
three or four days yeah that's that's
good I mean we went to like Bangkok I
thought that like traveling to a city
for like two or three days is like a
really good way to kind of just get a
feel for the vibe and try some food I I
think it's like an awesome amount of
time as well because have you ever been
to like a place where you've booked it
out for a week and after three days
you're like I'm done yeah yeah yeah
we've got four more days of this I'd
rather leave a place wishing I stayed
more yeah than staying there too long
and wishing I left earlier yeah exactly
so it's like you know I can always come
back sure yeah so I'm already like
planning to go back to Vietnam when I
can I want to explore more of the
country as well because yeah the two
three days was more kind of like a Vibe
check if I kind of like Vibe with the
place there and now I wanna I wanna
scoot all around Vietnam man I want to
do a road trip around Vietnam on
scooters man that's trash day specials
yeah literally I came back to Vietnam
and I was like a changed man because I
would not stop talking about scooters I
like the first if you've been talking
about scooters
yeah how was it uh scooting around
Hawaii Joey dude so good yeah like I I
knew I was gonna enjoy it because like
you know I've always wanted to ride the
scooter for the longest time but like
it's not really a thing in Australia for
one because Australia's just like too
big you can't get around in the scooter
yeah and in Japan you need to get like a
license which I'm going to get now that
I'm a changed man so I was like we had
the opportunity to write one in in
Hawaii because they're so easy to get
and they're so affordable to get yeah so
yeah like I think uh one of the days
like
um in the middle of the convention uh
all three of us you know we went out we
Connor did the stream and uh got Nye and
Nabi were on our mopeds and yeah we just
drove around for like two three hours
around like the coastline this beautiful
[__] Coast yeah it was really nice
like Cliff uh like area
um it was nice to get out of the city
honestly oh my God riding on that road
was just Enlightenment it was so good
right the giant truck or I'm sorry it's
not called the trucks it's a Jeep
truck people get annoyed if you refer to
a Jeep as a truck oh really yeah
apparently a Jeep is not a truck as I
found out even if it is in the style of
a pickup truck yeah it's very much a
truck it is not a truck because there's
always a Jeep when it's a Jeep yeah um
which I rented and that was fun to drive
I just wanted to rent the biggest car
they had available and just just feel
like a menace on the road you want to
feel America I want to feel America yeah
I want to get it and I feel like I do
get it yeah there's a there is a a joy
that comes from having a car that can
always handle every situation and handle
as many people as you need and if you
need to move [__] even I didn't move
[__] well you tried to the Vespa that is
a big fail oh yeah that's all right yeah
I mean like I I think the the reason we
went like scooter gang aside from you
know me being going through a phase now
I go I guess are you in your scooter
phase
third life crisis yeah yeah what is this
I've got like 32 years of scooting to
get back in my system that I missed out
yeah like I'm like making his whole
personality is going to be like scooting
like one of those like people get into
rock climbing but they're like yeah
actually my whole thing is now scooted
actually I'm just I actually like I have
gloves yeah
he's like what's CC mean I refuse to
scoot without my leather glass it's just
wild so you can you can always tell what
phase I'm going through by looking at my
YouTube recommendations and right now
like my entire homepage is just
motorbike and scooter videos so you can
definitely tell the kind of phase I'm
going through so the actual seat height
You're Gonna Want For Your Vespa is
actually dependent wholly on your leg
length there's just videos like that
right yeah oh my God
yeah I mean um
uh aside from you know one you know
going through that phase I I've never
been sold on having a big ass truck or
driving a big ass vehicle what makes no
sense in anywhere else in the world yeah
yeah in my mind I'm always I'm always
thinking about parking no matter how no
matter how good the drive is parking is
always in the back of my mind and just
seeing that massive vehicle I know for a
fact that I'm like as much if I'm
enjoying this ride I'm going to like
Dread Park in this vehicle well you know
just get good just get a good probably
get good yeah I say that but a lot of
you had to help me park one a few times
when we're in Japan yeah um but uh I
mean in America the parking spots are so
[__] big yeah so it's actually it's
not in the UK it'd be a miserable
experience because they're significantly
smaller like I I just don't think I
would even consider owning a truck or
Jeep yeah in any other country other
than America because it's just yeah it's
like you're actually just
inconveniencing it'll probably work in
Australia could work in Australia and
probably some parts of the UK actually
could work yeah like the countryside
stuff yeah if you were if you were not
driving into the cities at all it'd be
fine but yeah if you're dude like in
America it's so easy to drive a pickup
truck because it's just that all the
lanes are big there's no roundabouts
everything's just lanes and every
parking spot is [__] massive yeah the
drive-throughs can fit trucks like it's
like this is this is ridiculous yeah I
used to drive through a drive through in
a seven-seater like Volkswagen people
carrier kind of family car in the UK and
that that was that was scary going
through the drive-through in there
because that was just about it would get
in right and the pickup truck no shot oh
yeah
um so yeah I don't know it's kind of fun
I just kind of liked it and the roof
could pop off it was fun man it just
felt like you were just above the road
like I I I I get these and that's why
it's a tank right yeah and I get the
appeal because I think like certain cars
like if I indicated I think they'd be
like I'll let him go
it weirdly felt like I don't know if
it's because people were just politer in
Hawaii but from what I when I'd been in
the car a bunch when driving with like
either like American friends or if I was
an Uber like people would not be that
like generous like a Prius I don't know
if it was I don't know what it was
what's gonna happen if you crash you're
not even gonna feel it you're gonna it's
gonna be like you know